and you can party with the calls this
sunday at the west gate with st jude's
rants for children's sixth annual wine
women and shoes fundraiser here to tell
us more is dr christina vela with the
saint jews ranch and one of their
entertainers is bucky heard from the
righteous brothers it's good to see you
guys to see you hi it's great to have
you here in studio
i had the the privilege of touring the
facilities this past fall but tell
everyone about st jude's ranch and what
you guys do yeah for over almost almost
56 years we have been serving southern
nevada's most vulnerable children and
young people child victims of abuse and
neglect homeless youth and our newest
project to care for child victims of sex
trafficking so this weekend is the big
fundraiser to help your calls and help
everybody out wine women and shoes yep
great combination
right
we're sold what's happening on sunday at
the west gate well it's a ton of fun
it's an opportunity for our community to
come out and support a great charity
there's shopping our beautiful
huntington jewel you are drinking gold i
am literally dripping in gold huntington
jewelers is one of our incredible
sponsors it's at the westgate
resort and it's just going to be a great
time of shopping entertainment of course
amazing entertainment
and ultimately it's to raise funding to
support so many children and young
people in our community in need so it's
a win-win situation it certainly is and
talk about entertainment bucky it is
great to see you again you and i met
earlier this year and yeah you're a
world-class entertainer what can we
expect this weekend uh man you know it
it's going to be
raising money for this great cause is is
the main thing but we want to have a
good time and everybody's just going to
thoroughly enjoy themselves i'm going to
be joined
by nieve milandra who's also an amazing
singer
she's coming in later in the day i'm
going to be there sometime around what 2
45 3 o'clock somewhere there and just
just coming in to support the cause and
i'm gonna sing a few songs for everybody
and uh you know it's it's it's it hits
home with me i have a a 16 year old
daughter and uh
anything that i can do to help these
young ladies um i think you guys serve
from from zero up to 20 25 years old
and it's it's just a huge um
a huge honor for me uh to be able to
step in and be a part of this i'm just
glad i was able to do it and be off the
road we've been pretty busy lately so
yeah you guys are busy we're back man
you are back we're happy you're back and
it says a lot about you bucky too
because you give back to this community
and that's what makes las vegas great
entertainers like yourself giving back
dr vela i do want to talk real quick
there there's a best shoe contest there
is we have celebrity judges what's going
on we have celebrity judges uh jennifer
romas uh trina marie uh and with lots of
amazing judges they'll be best in shoe
for women and sexy stiletto and best
best in shoe contest and they'll be an
overall best for men's shooting shoes
because of course we want the guys to
get involved also they'll be
judging and prizes and the event has so
many fun elements shopping silent
auction live auction so much uh great
stuff coming together i'm going to do my
little set yeah and then i'm going to
just enjoy everything i can't i can't
wait to see what i was going on like
like christina said that the west gate
is just incredible
everybody there is just just amazing
iconic status of westgate absolutely i
gotta wrap it wrap it up bucky do me
niners you never close your eyes anymore
when i kiss your lips and there's notes
in the nest like before in your
fingertips i'm singing bill's part
oh my gosh thank you so much bucky we
appreciate it thank you there are still
tickets available this weekend sunday
over at the westgate for wine women and
shoes saints used rants for children's
sixth annual wine women's shoes westgate
starts at one o'clock to get tickets
tables all the information visit saint
jude